[Musica]
Billy ora ti distruggo il telefono no è
il secondo basta no i miei capelli
no E oggi nuova lezione con la maestra
strosa
e la maestra tritaossa è
tornata finalmente tornata come
finalmente come Finalmente ho
paura sì e forse un po' di paura anch'io
ce l'ho prima
lezione educazione
fisica dovrete correre in questo
percorso e fare lo srano ma non dovete
far cadere questo uovo se lo fate cadere
punizione e a me piace tantissimo delle
punizioni io sarò l'arbitro di questa
competizione sarò un arbitro giusto
preciso e soprattutto non voglio che
nessuno Bari perché se Bari Cioè nel
senso che tu fai le cose non bene verrai
squalificato e questo è il mio turno Non
vedo l'ora è un gioco da ragazzi guarda
È facilissimo portare l'uovo e fare lo
slalom pronti pron hai posti di partenza
fischio fischio
arbitro
vi
qua Aspetta un attimo questa Challenge è
troppo facile aggiungiamo una nuova
difficoltà da adesso in poi Voi dovrete
scappare da me e dal mio
[Musica]
martello Oh no povero Vitale è inseguito
dalla maestra trita Otta la maestra
cattiva è sempre cattiva non si
smentisce
mai sono Sicur che qualcuno prenderà
delle
botte Aspetta ma potrei essere io
Ah hai fatto cadere
l'uovo Vai vai non ti f mare vai maestra
Prendilo botte botte botte botte che
ce Ahia ahia ah ah B ho finito lo St
baglia basta basta me ne vado a mangiare
adesso Così impari Eh non ci gioco più
vado a
mangiare Adoro fare educazione fisica
così Vitale è stato
[Musica]
squalificato povero Vitale è stato
squalificato ma non mi sembrava tanto
triste Sarà andato a mangiare tutto in
cucina ma ora tocca a me devo riuscire a
non far cadere questo uovo e fare lo
slalom Così la maestra non riuscirà a
raggiungermi forse voi cliccate mi piace
per portarmi fortuna bene Ora tocca a te
[Risate]
Anita aiuto aiuto
aiuto
aiuto la
[Musica]
maestra Ah che bello Vai maestra Vai
maestra non sono l'unico a venire
Martellato dalla
maestra
[Musica]
ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta l'uovo è
intero mi ho completato il
percorso fine Anita è riuscita a
completare la gara Brava amita Uffa però
mi stavo divertendo però Anita Davvero
complimenti Ora tocca a Billy Ah
Incredibile anche Anita ha preso delle
martellate Oh lo vedo lo vedo la mia
vittoria la vedo per la prima volta
posso
vincere Ora è il turno di Billy e il
bullo Sì tocca a me e c'è area di
Vittoria Per Billy il
[Musica]
bullo ah
Ahia basta Billy ha fatto un cadere
tutti i coni quindi
squalificato
MRA Estra Billy hai fatto cadere tutti i
coni Oh
no
la maestra sta inseguendo Billy si è
dovuto nascondere sopra l'albero pur di
non essere preso benli stabil il bullo
se una brutta maestra
antipatica Se solo fossi un po' più
forte di te Te la farei vedere io Hai
capito se ti azzardi a scendere io ti
sbrano Però io allora non posso scendere
da qui morirò qui va bene morirò qui
Preferisco morire qui che scendere e
essere sbranato da da quella maestra
[Musica]
eh ah
ben C Sta Billy fine della prima
[Applauso]
Challenge in questa nuova Challenge il
mio compagno di classe è il mio
cagnolino Merlino visto che Vitale è
scappato a
[Musica]
mangiare sei bravo a scuola Merlino Hai
studiato Che lingua parli tu parli solo
la lingua dei cani e come faremo a
capirci seconda Challenge lezione di
francese l'altra volta non avete
studiato inglese vediamo ora se avete
studiato francese Io volevo la Challenge
in tedesco perché in tedesco avrei
indovinato tutte le parole tutte nessuna
esclusa perché Io sono tedesco tedesco
della Germania e come sempre chi non ha
studiato avrà delle punizioni e invece
Chi ha studiato vincerà il libro di
Anita la città stregata e adesso io
scriverò la prima parola in francese e
voi la dovete
tradurre Vitale tocca a te piena la
lavagna Oh no è già scappato nella prima
Challenge vi ricordate è andato a
mangiare in cucina Spero che arrivi
subito altrimenti la maestra tritaossa
si arrabbierà tantissimo E chissà che
punizione gli farà
Vitale Vitale
Vitale cosa è
successo È possibile che ogni santa
volta e ogni 5 minuti Dev andare a
mangiare qualche cosa in cucina tocca a
te vieni all lavagna Sbrigati ah Ok Ok
arrivo ma maestra e e qua ha dimenticato
una F Sfinge non singe spinge con la F
la spinge quella degli egizi No quella
che non è italiano Vitale Ah non è
italiano Ah allora è singe inglese Sing
Sing Sing Boh non lo so Ah ho capito è
Sing cantare sono troppo forte in
inglese ma non è neanche inglese stupido
si
pronunce hai capito Stupido Ah si
pronuncia assage come assagiare mi piace
questa parola perché assagio E allora
assaggia
Questo che schifo che
schifo
S significa
scimmia
[Musica]
Che cosa è questa cosa Che cosa è questa
cosa Oh Vitale si è trasformato in un
gorill ho spiato tut zone fino adesso e
ora io mi fingerò un francese perché
così la maestra penserà che io sia un
francese e vincerò questa
Challenge hai visto Billy con quel
cappello si crede un vero francese Sì
crede di essere un francese però allaa
fine Lui prenderà molte botte dalla
maestra cattiva Non lo so Vediamo se
questa volta lui riesce ad imbrogliarlo
Ma ne dubito anch'io dubito però la
maestra Pando se ne accorge per Milli e
la fine
Ehi ma avete visto che cosa ho preso
Questo è il nuovo iPhone 15 Pro Max
perché l'altra volta la maestra me l'ha
distrutto il telefono l'ha buttato in
terra l'ha Tutto distrutto l'avete visto
ma la maestra questo non lo deve vedere
L'ho appena comprato lo metto qui al
sicuro C per vieni all Lavagna
agrio
Traduci questa parola in
francese non c'è bisogno di del
gessetto io la leggo e posso tradurla
con la mia bellissima voce C vo Ma va la
devi tradurre bene per tradurre questa
parola c'ho bisogno di concentrazione
però mi ricorda un qualcosa di veramente
dilagante e io quando andavo lontano
andavo Nelle praterie della Germania e
ho incominciato a correre l ho capito
che cosa vuol dire chevo vuol dire
cavalli cosa cavalli Sì
cavall Ma cosa sta facendo schiappe
sembra un cavallo pazzo non un cavallo
normale Io cavalli Oddio Dio non vuol
dire cavalli vuol dire capelli questi E
ora la tua punizione sarà rasarti i
capelli Non ci posso credere la maestra
vuole rasare i capelli di schaffen e
questa è la tua
punizione no i miei capelli i miei
capelli che solo la scienza la mia
scienza non è possibile come posso fare
in effetti io sono diventato famoso
anche per i miei capelli e se io non
c'ho più i miei capelli come faccio a
diventare famoso no E poi la scienza no
maestra Lascia lascia i miei capelli non
puoi continuare a tagliare non posso
stare fermo perché non mi tutti i
capelli ma
maestra basta Ti metto una nota più
grande di te maale notta io non voglio
perdere i miei capelli maestro Lasciami
andare diventa tutta un'altra cosa io
voglio rimanere schiappelli sono
schiappe Oh non sono più schiappe senza
capelli non sono
più No non posso stare fermo Uffa Basta
no i miei capelli No no i miei
capelli
Ah sken ti ho fatto un ottimo lavoro
Tieni
Guardati però mi piace sembra un
alieno
chelato Poverino però fa anche ridere
schiappa il pelato ma d'ora in poi
rimarrà sempre così schiappa il
pelato Ah ha detto che sembra un alieno
ma in realtà sembra la testa di un uomo
sodo Beh schien ti piace il tuo nuovo
look mi sento un'aria fresca che
attraversa tutta la mia testa
bellissimo quindi preferisci essere così
che con i capelli No non è che
preferisco essere così voglio anche i
capelli però adesso va bene così va bene
scello di preoccupare Ti regalerò delle
parrucche delle parrucche E allora la
parrucca Proprio come la mia genialità
bella grande e molto affascinante
scrivete nei commenti che parrucca
volete che regali a schappen volete
vederlo rosso biondo Cartano Rosa
Celeste Fia scrivete nei
commenti adesso è il turno di Anita
vieni Anita Eccomi eccomi maestra
Allora Cosa vuol dire
uns Io adoro l'inglese ma non sono molto
brav in francese però questa parola è
abbastanza facile perché c'è scritto
ins e ed è molto simile alla parola in
inglese ma anche in italiano Quindi
immagino che questa parola voglia dire
in
Uffa hai indovinato io avevo già
preparato la
[Musica]
punizione però siccome hai indovinato me
Vai a posto Ora il mio
personaggio con bene maestro
[Musica]
me devo tradurre questa parola sì Ok è
faccilissimo perché io sono come può
vedere maestra io sono diventato par
Fran Io non sono Billy io J Io sono
bonon maestra so perché io sono Bon
perché io maestra vengo da Paris
Fran No aspetta Comè deve parlare in
francese perché io io vengo da
Disneyland Paris da Paris D
tu questo St di baghet sotto
l'ascella Ma cosa si sta inventando
Billy così fa arrabbiare ancora di più
la
maestra Ok maestra
aspetti Volevo dire maestra aspetti che
io adesso dico questo
mu sta giusto più qua e giusto più qua
Musta c c
Musta Che vuol dire no ma se non l'ho
neanche detto che cosa vuol dire No hai
sbagliato quindi cioè lei mi vuole solo
picchiare E allora lo Dicco maestra mi
vuole solo picchiare io me ne vado da
questa scuola va bene Io me ne vado da
questa Ah oh
qu Lo so lo
so
[Musica]
ah ahia va
Entra questo mi ha fatto male veramente
ah ahia
Maestra maestra Io lo so che cosa vuol
dire mustache posso dirlo schiappa
non è la tua
[Musica]
interrogazione ti è bastato quello che
ti ho fatto se non che ti faccio anche
le sopracciglia anche le
sopracciglia no le sopracciglia no E
allora le ciglia Le
ciglia Le ciglia ci devo pensare dipende
Ah che male e Ma la maestra È distratta
Questo è il mio momento per cercare Cosa
vuol dire la parola
Musta
Musta traduci dal francese Oh vuol dire
baffi Oh adesso lo so cosa vuol dire E
allora i pelli del naso i peli del naso
me li hanno levati da tanto tempo ormai
non ce li ho più e allora i peli delle
orecchie i peli delle orecchie anche
quelli me li avevo levati perché sennò
non ci sentivo bene e quindi me li hanno
levati già da tanto tempo in Germania
Certo che sei proprio strano
stippen Maestra maestra Maestra maestra
Sì io ce l'ho ce l'ho So cosa vuol dire
non ci crederà mai mi darà 10 e lode 10
e lode 10 ottimo
mustache
[Musica]
significa
baffi vero mm Billy questo è molto molto
strano come mai prima non lo sapevi E
ora Tutto ad un tratto Lo sai mi stai
forse nascondendo qualcosa nascondendo
qualcosa io no no no no no no sto
nascondendo proprio niente Io sono
Studiato francese perché io
vengo Francia che cosa stai nascondendo
dietro la schiena
Eh no io dietro non c'ho niente No no
non c'è niente No no non c'è niente non
c'è niente non c'è niente non c'è niente
non c'è niente no no no no no' no no
no il nuovo cellulare di
Billy Ecco come ha fatto Oh no il mio
telefono nuovo io ti avevo avvisato e
questa è la seconda volta no maestra il
mio telefono Oh il telefono nuovo no Lo
prego Lo prego Me lo dia No no Non me ne
frega Io ti avevo
avvisato
Billy ora ti distruggo il
telefono no è il secondo telefono
[Applauso]
no
e adesso Passiamo al vincitore di questa
sfida anitta hai vinto questa Challenge
Evviva Ma siccome io ce l'ho già il
libro La città stregata E voi ce l'avete
Se non ce l'avete prendetelo subito lo
regalo a
schippen la città stregata Anita stomen
bravo sai
leggere Mi dispiace per Billy ma ha
avuto quello che si meritava visto che è
imbrogliato e noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video ciao ciao ciao
ciao